- I went in for the group hug.
- I know. I was gonna get separate hugs.
- See I was trying to hog the hug.
- He's a hug hogger.
- You can have your
separate hug. Watch this.
- Thank you, Kelly.
- See, you don't get your separate hug.
- It's alright.
- I'm just kidding.
- You are college
sweethearts, is this true?
- Yes.
- We are.
- So you work together, you're
around each other a lot.
How're you making this work?
It's a lot of together time.
- It's the only way we can..
- We're obsessed with each other.
Well I'm obsessed with her.
- No, we're obsessed with each other.
- Okay.
- I had this huge, huge
crush on him in college
when we didn't know each other.
He was like a celebrity crush to me.
- The crush was mutual.
- [Kelly and Audience] Aw.
- [Woman] But we didn't know.
We didn't know each other.
- [Man] Hey, it's us.
- [Woman] Yeah. Yeah, there we are.
- [Kelly] Look how cute you are.
- I had way more hair on my head.
- It's right here now though.
You have way more hair here.
- And back here.
(Kelly clapping)
- Your hair's real good back here.
- [Kelly] Age is so
awesome, isn't it? Yeah?
- Yeah.
- And you're now raising,
is it two kiddos?
- [Woman] Yeah. Two little girls.
- Two little girls.
- Yes.
- That's a lot of estrogen,
my man. Good luck.
(audience laughter)
- Yes. One of 'em is
backstage with us right now.
- Oh really?
- She is. Yes.
- [Kelly] How old are they?
- Five and almost two.
- Oh, that's incredible.
Awesome. I have a six and eight year old.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- They're, they're just
fun ages. The young ones.
- [Woman] You're in the per-
like, primetime travel age.
Like we've been- we can't wait.
- So you're still stuck
with the diapers and
the stuff and the, yeah.
- We have a lot of gear for
the almost two year old,
but as soon as she...
- The day I didn't have
to take that bag, girl.
And I just was like, "hop in the car".
- Yeah.
- We go anywhere.
- I felt like, I felt
like I'd won the lottery.
- Yes
- I was like, I didn't look
like a Sherpa everywhere I went.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Woman] Yes.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- We're, we're gonna be there one day.
- I know, I don't mean to rub it in.
- But I'm enjoying her, her
baby-ness right now, still.
- Yeah. We'll get there.
We're gonna get there.
- That's adorable.
Okay, so tell everybody
about Hometown Takeover.
- Okay.
- The latest show.
- Hometown Takeover,
season two, is in Colorado.
This... we've never been to Colorado.
- Oh, I love Colorado.
- And last season was in Alabama.
- Yeah. Which is, you know,
Alabama and Mississippi.
You know, Alabama's just
the back of Mississippi.
(woman laughing)
- We're mirror images of each other.
- Yeah. So we were in the Prairie.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Which is Northeast Colorado.
Which does not look like
the Colorado of movies.
- Yeah.
- We didn't know.
We thought it was gonna
be in the mountains,
because we've never been to Colorado.
I just thought all of it
was the mountains and...
- It's a big flat desert.
- Yeah.
- It was.
- That's like Wyoming and Montana too.
There are parts that are so like
- Yes.
- You know, flat parts.
- [Woman] Very close to Wyoming right?
- Yeah, we were close to Wyoming.
- And so anyway, they were
one of the 6,000 towns
that submitted themselves for
consideration for season one.
And so HGTV chose the towns.
We did not choose favorites.
I wanna be very clear about that.
So Fort Morgan, Ben and
I work on the projects
like public spaces,
- [Ben] Yeah.
- [Woman] and community projects
The downtown facade update.
And then Dave and Jenny Mars are-
- [Ben] Work on the, the
more personal projects.
So they did like the homes and everything.
- [Woman] Residential stuff.
- [Ben] The residential side of it.
But our goal was trying
to help that town figure
out who they were.
It was, you know, how do
you brand a town, for lack
of a better term, into something
that will show, you know
the pride of the people that live there...
- [Kelly] Who they are.
- the pride of who they are.
And so that was what they, they landed on.
And we told them from the
beginning, we were like
"we are not going to come
up with this for you.
We need you to do this."
And so the town came up
with Oasis on the plains.
Because it literally, like when you
drive through a desert
landscape in the plains,
and then there's a
river in Fort Morgan and
it's just like this town
sprung up around it and...
- Which is great.
- [Ben] Yes.
- It's lush and it's beautiful and yeah.
- That's like Missoula, Montana.
There's a river that
goes right through it.
And it's like, yeah, that's,
it's beautiful to have that.
As your like base, your foundation.
- [Ben and woman] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Beautiful river.
- And so...
- We wanted to help 'em,
you know, you gotta know
who you are before you can
tell the story of who you are.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that was our big goal.
- That's so cool.
And to be able to bring
pride to a community and
and give them a different
kind of self-worth
in a different way.
- [Ben] Yeah.
That's a really beautiful thing.
- [Woman] Yes.
- What a great, like, vocation.
Like, well, great job.
Y'all get to do that.
- It's really fun.
- [Kelly] Yes
- It is.
- Well, thank y'all for coming everybody.
Hometown takeover premieres
April 23rd on HGTV.